there is a global mystery that we are
all
noodling right now i could not let this
story go by i
it has a lot of layers okay get ready
buckle up because we don't know what
this is
it is a true mystery and it is
fascinating
okay this is like real we don't know
but the story is a trail of monoliths
are cropping
up around the globe let me catch you up
to what we know cnn reported that the
first monolith
was found in the utah desert last week
and it has mysteriously vanished
and by the way this thing is not light
it's hundreds of pounds then
a similar monolith appeared in romania
but then that one disappeared several
days
later and now a third monolith has
appeared at the top of pine mountain in
san luis obispo county in california
and this one visually looks a little
different than the others no one has
solved the case yet
and there is a lot of speculation like
is it a marketing stunt
we know this the one in utah you can see
on google earth images
from a few years ago so i don't think
that is a marketing ploy
is it a gift from aliens to help bring
humanity together
over a globally shared mystery the new
york times has a theory that artist
john mccracken planted the first
monolith in utah before he died because
it's identical to some of his
we'll keep nancy drewing this one i just
love
a mystery you know what we even spotted
one
in our studio yeah but we removed it due
to foot traffic
i am fascinated there are so
many layers what's going to happen next
speaking of so
many layers delish reports
that now you can get your very own
stoppers lasagna
fanny pack have your lasagna on the go
with this great holiday gift
you strap it on and you open it up and
manja
some piping hot waste lasagna ready
because
i'm just saying so basically
first of all i love fanny packs and to
all you women out there
they're a really great way to keep track
of your uh fluctuating weight
fanny pack tightened good day fanny pack
loosen
not a great day i am just going to
yep there it is you know
i'm so sorry i'm just a little hungry
just gonna
[Applause]
this works stouffers if you are watching
call me i mean this i
i believe in the power of what you have
created
oh i'm sorry i gotta get back to work
hang on
oh my god okay here we go and by the way
my back is being heated just saying now
next i want to introduce someone that i
am a huge
fan of the cut posted a very big sparkly
feature on this
person and he's injected some much
needed joy into this year
with his impressions of banana breads
publicist and
your dirty dishes your clothes tag like
take a look
oh my god he's wearing he's wearing the
sweats again
he's wearing the exact same spot are you
okay
it's like it's like why even buy me like
he bought me like
three months ago and like i was i mean
i'm not gonna like brag about how much i
was but i was 180
like that's like that's some coin like
that's
you should want to wear me i i i can't i
love it so much
please welcome writer and impressionist
it's even hard to sum it up
jordan first men
oh my god girl how are you with
compliments are you good at receiving
them
no okay i am who i am because i've never
been kissed
if that makes sense it makes sense to me
because
i don't really take it as like my ego or
about me
i know that a group of the people that i
work with
and we started flower films that was our
first official film
and we made it for those who felt
isolated to be less alone
yeah and like you just it also
just on a technical film level drew
it's the one it's like beat by beat it's
just
rom-com perfection i love that
you see a pair of sweatpants with a tag
and talk about like the money that's
been spent and why they're not being
worn
or the fly you know on mike pence's head
or the myriad of fantastical scenarios
the banana bread like
how does your brain work the way it does
i mean drew i believe in
the biggest being the smallest if that
makes sense
so like everything is part of one thing
and the smallest part of us is also the
biggest part of humanity
and so when i look at
the world i see a tree and i'm like
that's me
and i see a pair of shoes and i'm like
that's me
because i'm part of it well i used to be
obsessed with animism
which is to believe that inanimate
objects have a soul and i believe
anything is possible and my biggest hope
in the world
is that we allow each other to believe
what is possible for
ourselves so it's like that's what i'm
trying to do in my comedy too is bring a
real
positivity and joy i think that's why
people are gravitating towards them
i love that you are positive because
if there is a vulnerability and a
kindness and a humor
and a sort of we're going to leap
together oh my god
i think there's something you do tend to
root for that
a lot more than that of someone who is
rising by bringing someone else down
what if you could get to the top by
being nice to people
and by liking everyone around you and by
creating a positive work environment
like what if that brought you to the top
and i think like work
can be fun and even if you're not doing
what you absolutely love what your heart
speaks to you can at least
try to have a good time the work will be
better if we have a good time
let's kick it i totally agree and there
is
you know such a new opportunity out
there
for people and there are the benny
dramas and the chloe fineman's and i
feel like you guys are all friends in
the community
and people are taking this platform
and being so imaginative with it but
now i'm really excited because i hear
you have a new video
to unveil today with us yeah
i it's it's kind of inspired by someone
you might know well okay well let's take
a look
okay so i've been like toying with the
idea of
making this girl and like i want to make
her a star
like she's going to be a star but i have
this idea
for this voice i'm like hearing this
voice and it's like
a voice that's never been done before no
one's ever heard it
and i kind of want to give it to this
girl but
i'm just worried that it will make her
like too cute
too irresistible that like america will
just become like
obsessed and like that's a lot of energy
to put on
someone i think she can handle it though
i'll just make it so she can handle it
yeah
i'm just gonna give her the voice i'm
gonna give her the voice yeah
drew drew drew barrymore oh my god
i am good at what i do i'm sorry not to
brag but i'm good at what i do
drew barrymore obviously
yeah that made me feel so good
that was so kind and humbling and sweet
i hope i can live up to that that's you
can you already did
god god was like she can handle it all
thank you for thinking i could handle it
thank you for thinking
all those things that's so lovely jordan
you're so special
and i just am such an admirer of yours
and that one really shut me down
i don't even know what to say thank you
i
think that what you and the new crew is
putting out there
you are it's the new crew do you
remember like there was when i was
younger there was like
the brat pack which was you know
the rat pack but it was the molly
ringwalds and the jud nelsons and the
whole john huseyian crew
and i think that you guys are really the
new crew and you found
a way to put yourselves out there in
your most authentic imaginative way
and thank you